BOTTOM OF IT.
>> IT'S A BIG COMPARISON, SEAN.
>> Sean: THANK YOU, SIR.
JOINING US NOW, HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN DEVIN
NUNES.
IT IS NOW INEVITABLE,
CONGRESSMAN.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF IF, IT'S A
MATTER OF WHEN.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT FIVE
SEPARATE, EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE,
MORE.
NOW THE PRESIDENT THE
CLASSIFIEDS, THE GAME CHANGER,
THE IG REPORT, AND MR. GORHAM,
AND JOHN HUBER, AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TELL US WHAT YOU SEE UNFOLDING
AND WHEN.
>> I WANT TO START TO MAKE SURE
WHAT MUELLER DID YESTERDAY, I
THOUGHT HE DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB
BUT PEOPLE FORGET ONE IMPORTANT
POINT.
MUELLER TRYING TO DO THIS A
VICTORY LAP.
HE TRIED TO TALK ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS THEY FOUND, THE
RUSSIANS THEY PROSECUTED.
I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT THE
HOUSE REPUBLICANS ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE HAD THAT
OVER A YEAR AGO.
AND MUELLER, OR IF HE'S SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE RUSSIANS,
WHY DID THEY OBSTRUCT OUR REPORT
FROM GETTING OUT?
SO ALL REPORT IS STILL HEAVILY
REDACTED, SEAN.
SO MUELLER -- EXACTLY RIGHT, HE
LIT THE FUSE.
YOU ASK ABOUT WHAT YOU COME
FIRST?
I THINK THE THING THAT SHOULD
COME FIRST IS, NUMBER ONE, WE
STILL DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
MUELLER WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
INVESTIGATING.
WE DO NOT HAVE THAT DOCUMENT.
WE KNOW THAT HE'S TALKED ABOUT
CONSPIRACY TO COLLUDE?
WELL, WHEN HE WALKS IN THE DOOR,
HE KNEW THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE THE LEAD
INVESTIGATOR SAID SO ON TEXT
MESSAGES.
HE WAS SO BLATANTLY DISHONEST
YESTERDAY THAT HE SAYS, WELL,
THE OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL SAYS
THAT YOU CAN'T INDICT A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
WELL, HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN GONE
AFTER DAY TWO.
HE HAS NO RUSSIANS, EXCEPT FOR
THE FUSION AND CLINTON RUSSIANS,
AND POSSIBLY THE DIRTY COP AT
THE EYE RUSSIANS.
THAT'S THE ONLY RUSSIANS HE HAS
TO SHOW CONNECTIONS TO THE
MUELLER CAMPAIGN.
CLEARLY THE CLINTON OPERATION IS
HEAVILY WORKING WITH RUSSIANS OR
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
HE DIDN'T TAKE TIME TO LOOK INTO
ANY OF THAT.
AND YOU HAVE THIS, HE COMES AND
SAYS WELL, THERE IS NO
POSSIBILITY TO INDICT THE
PRESIDENT ON OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF
SITTING BACK THINKING ABOUT IT,
WHAT WAS THAT PRESS CONFERENCE
ALL ABOUT YESTERDAY?
IT WAS ONE THING.
TO LIGHT THE FUSE.
LIGHT THE FUSE FOR IMPEACHMENT.
BECAUSE THESE GUYS ARE IN BIG
TROUBLE.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT POINT.
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE, HE HAD
TO CLARIFY ABOUT THAT JOINT
STATEMENT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> WELL, THAT WAS BARR ACTUALLY
BEING A GROWN-UP AND HAD TO
REMIND MUELLER, WE HAVE YOU ON
THE RECORD THREE DIFFERENT TIMES
SAYING THAT YOU WERE -- YOU
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION
TO INDICT ON OBSTRUCTION.
IT HAD NOT TO DO WITH THE
POSITION OF THE OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL.
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
POINT THAT I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD
REMEMBER ABOUT, AND I THINK THAT
YOU HAVE COMEY WITH DIARRHEA OF
THE MOUTH IN THE POST.
HE A SUPPOSEDLY NEW ABOUT THE
DIRT ON CLINTON.
YES, THE PROFESSOR.
HE CALLED THEM A RUSSIAN ASSET.
REMEMBER, IN THE MUELLER
DOSSIER, MUELLER STOPPED SHORT
OF CALLING HIM A RUSSIAN ASSET.
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR WHO
STARTED THIS INVESTIGATION CAN'T
EVEN GET FULL COMMUNICATION WITH
THE MUELLER DOSSIER PEOPLE.
JUST TO FINISH UP AND PUT A
FINAL POINT ON THIS, YOU WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT THIS IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE, WISEMAN AND ANOTHER
ATTORNEY THERE, HANDLED THE
STEELE DOSSIER IN AUGUST OF
2016.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THESE ARE HIGH-LEVEL PEOPLE.
BRUCE OHR, ANDREW WEISSMANN, AND
OTHER PEOPLE WHO WORKED ON THE
FORMER DOSSIER TEAM COME UP THEY
ARE LOOKING AT THIS VERY
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED
INFORMATION AND NOT ONE OF THEM
SITS THERE AND SAYS, WHERE DOES
THIS COME FROM, BRUCE OHR?
WHERE DID THIS COME FROM?
OH, MY WIFE IS DOING IT.
MY WIFE IS WORKING FOR FUSION
DPS WORKING FOR THE DEMOCRATS
AND CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THAT WAS A WHOLE THING.
IT'S SO SERIOUS BUT YOU WANT TO
LAUGH.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME YOU HOPE
THAT JUSTICE IS ACTUALLY SERVED
FOR THESE CRIMINALS.
>> Sean: IF YOU LISTEN TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHEN HE WENT
BEFORE SENATOR GRAHAM'S
COMMITTEE, IS HE INTERESTED
WANTING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE FISA ABUSE?
WE KNOW THAT BRUCE OHR BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS TESTIFIED, HE
WARNED EVERYBODY THAT HILLARY
PAID FOR IT, STEELE HATES TRUMP.
TEN DAYS BEFORE, A
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
CATHERINE
BEFORE COMEY SIGNED OFF, SAYS
VERIFIED BUT AN UNVERIFIABLE
DOCUMENT, BUT STEELE DOESN'T
STAND BY HIS OWN WORDS.
ARE THOSE PEOPLE GOING TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
DO YOU SEE ANY WAY THEY GET OUT
OF WHAT I WOULD THINK IS AN
INDICTMENT TO COMMIT FRAUD AND A
FISA COURT, AN INDICTMENT TO
LITERALLY RIG AN INVESTIGATION
IN THEIR FAVORITE CANDIDATE AND
HILLARY CLINTON, AND TO USE
RUSSIAN LIES TO TAKE DOWN A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT?
CAN THEY GET AWAY WITH THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK THE EASIEST
THING TO PROSECUTE ON ARE THE
LEAKS, THE LIGHT, AND
OBSTRUCTING CONGRESSES
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT I WILL SAY IN CLOSING, IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
THIS WHOLE INVESTIGATION, YOU'VE
GOT A LOT OF AREAS FOR THE
JUSTICE OF THE APARTMENT TO LOOK
AT.
DO NOT FORGET THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
THE DIRTY COPS IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND WHOEVER
FROM THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
WORKING WITH THE DIRTY COP TO
GET INFORMATION FROM RUSSIA.
>> Sean: WOULD IT BE FAIR TO
SAY THAT WHEN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE SEEN WHAT YOU HAVE
SEEN, IT WILL SHOCK THE
CONSCIENCE AND SOUL OF THIS
COUNTRY?
>> I ALWAYS SAY, ON THE FISA
APPLICATION ESPECIALLY, YOU
HEARD COMEY CALL IT A MOSAIC.
PEOPLE NEED TO SEE WHAT'S THERE.